Speaker 1: Let's start with the most fun possible
segment we ever do, which is a review of where
we are with the coronavirus pandemic.
I know it's really a party.
We haven't done a review of covid cases and
deaths lately because it's just been so busy
on the show.
But now, in the context of some declining
vaccination and changing mass guidelines,
which we will get to, this is worth doing.
I believe we are now three weeks from a massive
reduction in covid cases and just a little
more than three weeks from a massive reduction
in covid deaths.
Now, keep me honest on this.
This means May 19, three weeks from today,
I've marked it in the calendar.
I believe covid numbers will be looking really
good in the United States.
And we're going to come back and see if that
actually happens.
Let's start with cases and then we'll talk
about what's going on.
So to begin with, as a reminder, the U.S.
has had essentially four case spikes.
The first was that first spike in March of
twenty twenty, the second in July of 2012,
summer of twenty twenty, the third and the
biggest in the winter of 2020 into January
of twenty twenty one.
And that is case has started to come down
rapidly during the vaccination phase in February
and in March, cases kicked back up a little
bit.
Why did this happen?
Well, it's believed that it was because some
people started going nuts too soon even though
they weren't vaccinated.
And then also we had that British variant,
the B one one seven variant in the northeast
of the U.S., in Michigan and a few other places.
And it was actually starting to outrun vaccines.
We seem to have turned that around.
Case numbers now coming down in Michigan.
It now seems we vaccinated quickly enough
that we are back into some semblance of control
in what is big picture and out of control
situation.
Remember that the vaccines work well against
all the variants, to some degree less so against
the South African variant, but still does
does.
Well, cases are now down about 20 percent
from that mini peak a month ago.
So from that little peak, we're already down
20 percent.
We're down 78 percent in cases per day from
the big peak in the middle of January.
That should continue down.
Now, the death curve, the death curve has
been more nuanced, but it also didn't really
experience any resurgence in the past couple
of months.
Even though cases went back up, deaths did
not.
Deaths peaked in late January, around 3400
per day.
Just an incredible, horrifying number.
They are now down to about seven hundred and
twenty five deaths a day.
Still terrible, but continuing to decline.
We are down about 80 percent in daily deaths,
but 20 percent of that peak is still a lot.
The death decline can take longer because,
I mean, quite morbidly, it takes time to die
from covid.
So there are people who have been sick for
a while who will continue to die even as more
people are protected by the vaccine.
People who would have died in June, did they
not get vaccinated today?
It takes a little time to see the impact of
that.
But by Memorial Day, hopefully death numbers
will also be really low.
Now, unfortunately, these case and death declines
are coming as we are seeing reduced vaccination
numbers.
This is not because of the brief pause to
the Johnson and Johnson vaccine.
It is not because there aren't vaccines available.
This is increasingly a demand issue after
a long period of vaccination increasing all
the way up to an average of three and a half
million doses per day, we were hoping we would
get to four or even five million doses per
day.
We did not.
We are now back down to two point seven million
doses per day, continuing to decline only
two point one and one point seven million
doses per day in each of the last two days.
There are lots of vaccination centers in blue
states, red states, north, south, everywhere,
saying you don't need an appointment, just
show up and get a vaccine.
We should soon see approval of the Phizer
vaccine for people aged 12 to 15, hopefully
Moderna as well.
That will add people to the demand.
But we are getting to where more and more
of the people that want a vaccine have gotten
it, or at least the first dose waiting on
a second.
So we are now going to need new initiatives
to encourage people to go out and get the
vaccine.
Today, I will be talking about Joe Rogan's
recent anti vaccine comments, which I find
very dangerous.
Many of you wrote to me about them saying,
David, why won't you criticize your friend
Joe Rogan?
All right.
Well, we're going to do it today.
It's very dangerous.
We do not need things said now that will encourage
people not to get vaccinated.
So that will.
Yes, I will talk about my friend Joe Rogan.
We will talk about it today.
But even if we can keep doing two million
doses a day, we're still going to be looking
quite good by the middle of June.
And that's where we are today.
This stuff matters.
We now have.
As I told you earlier, more relaxed or rather,
as I told you yesterday, we would get and
we will discuss in detail later today, I realize
it's unclear to say I told you earlier.
I told you yesterday.
And now we have the new guidelines.
We have more relaxed mass guidelines because
people have been getting vaccinated because
the vaccines are so effective.
At the same time, we're nowhere near out of
the global catastrophe.
I'm putting up on the screen the chart, the
case chart from India, which we discussed
on a previous show.
And it is a disaster.
People are literally dying in the streets.
In India, a video came out of two sons on
a motorcycle transporting their dead mother,
holding her upright on the motorcycle because
all services she died of covid.
All services are collapsing in India.
Even in Canada, cases have been spiking and
things have not been looking so good.
So this will be a continued and long global
process, which will hopefully look much better
in some countries.
As soon as a few weeks from now, we're going
to get to the masking.
We're going to get the vaccination later.
But that's where we are on cases
and deaths.